- If I went trick-or-treating,
and someone put this in my bag,
I'd come back and egg their house.
(midtempo pop music)
- I'm Australian, so I've
never actually had candy corn.
I've only seen it in movies.
- Hate it.
I think it just tastes horrible.
It's like corn syrup and stripping paint.
- I think one of the best
things about it becoming fall
is that it's appropriate
to buy candy corn without judgement.
- I think there's probably
a good intersection
between people who love candy corn
and people who love brunch.
- (laughs) Yeah.
The texture already looks
a little weird for me.
Oh.
- It's syrupy.
- You move it like this.
That's how you make it a
tooth, like a snaggletooth.
- Cheers, Chloe.
- Cheers. (laughs)
- It's chalky, a, that's not
the normal candy corn texture.
- Where's the chocolate?
- There's none.
- Tastes like pancake
batter really strongly,
with a little chocolate aftertaste.
- At first I really tasted the chocolate
and the pancake batter kind of vibe,
but then, when you mentioned.
- When the syrup came in, it ruined it!
- It kind of tastes like if you were
to finish a plate of pancakes,
leave the plate for like an
hour, come back and lick it,
it's a little bit like what
it tastes like. (laughs)
- Fake fruit flavor is always a hard one.
Are you just eating it all at once?
- Yeah.
Whoa!
- It was very, that
sugary strawberry flavor
where it's not really tasting
like a strawberry at all.
- It's just such a weird aftertaste,
like I just wanna take my tongue out
and rub it on the carpet or something.
- The first taste immediately
is fake strawberry,
almost like medicine, but the good kind,
like that pink one you'd
have when you were a kid.
However, after two seconds,
it really turns into a waffle.
That was crazy.
- I like this one a lot.
- They all smell a little
bit like cleaning solution.
- Whoa.
(uncertain giggles)
- That tastes nothing
like (bleep) french toast.
- This is actually the
least intense flavor.
It kind of just tastes
like buttery sweet bread.
- I love it.
- It's actually really good.
It tastes like butter,
that's why I like it.
I love butter.
- That was crazy!
What a subtle flavor.
What a subtle, beautiful
- I'm immediately going
back for another handful.
- Yeah, not even one, a handful.
- I'm on board.
- Would you have any of
these over a classic corn?
- No.
- No way.
- Candy corn should stay candy corn.
I don't think we should
go beyond those borders.
- I just feel like with any meal or lolly,
if you're gonna eat it, it might
as well be worth it, right?
'Cause it's not great for you, these.
Neither is brunch most of the time,
so it better be good.
- Candy corn's already hard to binge on,
this is even harder to binge on
- Yeah.
- Than normal candy corn.
- Um, I mean.
- Why did I just eat another one? (laughs)
- Why do you want that?
- I was just sitting here!
Oh!
(sign squeaks)